I want to thank everybody for coming
this is reasons first live stream I'm
Nick Gillespie and uh today we're
talking about
whether or not Ron DeSantis are good or
bad for Liberty
and I'm joined by Zach Weissmuller my uh
reason TV colleague as well as Carol
Markowitz I'm going to introduce them in
a little bit but just as a general setup
no Governor is more cheered and hated
right now than the Florida Republican
Ron DeSantis currently in the news for
flying around 50 Venezuelan migrants was
seeking Asylum uh Refugee status from uh
Venezuela to Martha's Vineyard the 44
Year Old Navy veteran and double IB
leader also headlined the third National
conservativism con conference where he
emphasized that the state should punish
and reward businesses and individuals
based on political positions
controversially DeSantis has yanked
long-standing tax rates for Walt Disney
Corporation after the company criticizes
stance on gay rights he signed
legislation that would limit social
media platforms ability to moderate
content and regulate users the law has
been blocked by a federal court he's
banned mask mandates in public schools
and issued an executive order
prohibiting businesses
from requiring proof of vaccination from
customers he's also pushed cities such
as Gainesville
to abandon zoning reform named at
creating more diverse multi-family
housing if such top-down edicts seem at
odds with traditional conservative
support for local decision making and
support for business interests DeSantis
has also gotten the high marks for
mostly keeping K-12 schools open during
the pandemic and overseeing a boom in
people moving to Florida to escape
lockdowns elsewhere when covet death
rates are adjusted for the age of
residents as they should be Florida's
rate is about the same as California as
Florida had 275 deaths per hundred
thousand people California's is 267 and
both of those are well below the
national average of 302 deaths per 100
000 people DeSantis is a strong
supporter of gun rights and signed a 1.2
billion dollar tax break package this
spring promising even more Cuts if and
when he gets reelected in November he's
running against former Governor current
Congressman Charlie Crist and is up in
the polls by about four or five points
despite increased levels of spending
each year of his governorship and part
of that's due to covid uh the state is
currently sitting on a 22 billion dollar
budget surplus Florida is also one of
those odd States wonderful states that
doesn't have an income tax so when
you're cutting taxes and there's not
even an income tax that's really saying
something
so how should Libertarians think about
Ron DeSantis is he a retaliatory culture
Warrior and the leading indicator of an
authoritarian convergence of the right
and the left as some of us have reason
upset or is he a successful large State
Governor uh the future of the Republican
party and quite possibly the next
president of these United States how
should Libertarians think about his mix
of bullying and raviora that is turning
the sunshine state from a joke we all
remember the Florida man stuff uh to one
of the hottest destinations in the
country
I am leading in uh this conversation
about DeSantis Florida and Libertarians
with two recent Blue State refugees uh
reason senior producer Zach wise Miller
uh I think you can figure out which one
he is he's the one that where it says
Zach Weissmuller under him so
heteronormative yes uh where nothing if
not heteronormative or at least Zach is
uh who pulled up Stakes with his family
from California uh about a year ago I
moved back to Florida he's a Florida
native and also New York Post columnist
Carol Markowitz who hightailed it out of
New York to uh to Florida earlier this
year in January and she had done a
five-month stint uh kind of trial run
during the covet lockdown as well Zach
and uh uh Carol thanks for joining thank
you for having me thanks Nick uh let's
start with the
um let's start with the migrant uh bit
you know Zach what uh how what what's
your sense of you know uh DeSantis
apparently paid about 1.6 million
dollars in in state funds to fly about
50 Venezuelans who are being processed
as a stylist in America to Martha's
Vineyard
um you know is this is this a good or
bad thing
I mean as a newly minted Floridian pay
paying as you mentioned lower taxes than
in California I still don't love the
idea of my tax dollars going to fly
people out of Texas to Martha's Vineyard
I mean we all see it for what it is it
was a stunt
um it got a lot of attention so I guess
it achieved its intended effect to me as
someone who's generally very
pro-immigration
um I I would you know I would love more
Venezuelans to come live in Florida
um I found it just really distasteful
embarrassing waste of money so Carol
what about you and you if I may you were
an actual Refugee from Congress and from
the Soviet Union
um what do you think about this so you
know well part of that you know having
that as my background is I kind of know
the process and I mean it obviously has
changed since the late 70s somewhat
um but I didn't my family didn't get on
a flight and land in JFK like Hey we're
here take us in
um we actually we had to spend time in
Italy uh so first of all we had to
re-let out of the Soviet Union how do
you get let out that's you know
political pressure was applied on the
Soviet Union to let us out but the
second part was being accepted in
somewhere and in order to be accepted in
somewhere someone had to vouch for you
someone had to say that when they get
here we will take care of them and for
Soviet Jews a lot of the time it was
Jewish organizations in America
without that just bare minimum of
support uh I don't understand how we can
continue allowing people in in mass and
not have anybody waiting for them is it
a good thing I mean would you have felt
pissed off if you were you know you were
the mother and suddenly you know you
sign a bunch of papers you may not even
know exactly what's going on and you end
up at Martha's Vineyard and you realize
that you are you know just a prop in
some kind of weird problem well I don't
know I mean if I if I came without any
you know a permission to come or
anything like that I think I would
expect that you know my life might be a
little difficult especially in the early
days and I think what the scientists did
here is bring the problems of the border
to people who are completely inoculated
from this they never have to deal with
the policies that they support and so
yeah
I mean Florida is not a border state he
did he did why didn't he take the why
didn't he you know I mean because he he
won't shut up about Cubans coming
fleeing Venezuelan yeah bring them to
Florida and you know and they would fit
right in I would be I think Venezuelans
in a lot of cases would be natural
Americans but look you know when again
when my family came here it wasn't like
America said hey Soviet Union anybody
who feels oppressed over there you know
come on in it was really targeted and so
we've had this problem in the last few
years where there is no target there is
no
um amount of people that we're allowing
in per year there's actually no
guidelines at all that we follow and so
why is DeSantis doing it I mean you know
just my my guess here is that all eyes
on him because he is sort of the natural
you know leader of the Republican party
right now and whatever he does kind of
resonates with the rest of the party and
he sets the agenda what how do you feel
about that I just want to ask you know
as a my fellow Floridian here like how
do you feel we should point out though
you guys are North Florida and South
Florida oh yes yeah
well yeah yeah well I you know um just
the fact that it clearly yes DeSantis is
uh kind of becoming the de facto face of
the new Republican party and he's doing
you know this is a stunt to send a a
message
um but you you know what what was it I
would say it's not just a message yeah
it's to effect policy I think again like
if if the people who are making the
policy I have to live by those policies
where migrants do just show up on their
doorstep the way that they do in you
know in places in Texas
um the way that the migrants just walk
across people's backyards to get in I
mean it's just it's happening and it's
been happening and the resources have
been really stretched in Texas so when
when the people of Martha's Vineyard are
like oh my God 50 people what are we
gonna do it really does not only send
the message but also affect the way that
they see this problem
but as a floor like does that Advance
you know this is always the problem when
you have a governor who is you know
starting to run for president is like is
this really helping the people of
Florida because that you know moving to
Florida I was kind of like well you know
DeSantis and we're going to get into all
this but he seemed to be making a lot of
good calls that were in the best
interest of the people living in Florida
and now I feel like there's a level of
you know the the eye is somewhere else
now
um do you feel that as well
Carol how did we lose Carol okay
I think we well she's she's Frozen there
Carol do you want to uh drop out and
come back in you could do that
um
um well Zach what you know do we know uh
desantis's take on immigration because
this is you know it's one thing to call
um to call attention to you know the uh
situation at the border which is pretty
[ __ ] up yeah and it has been that way
for a long time you'll recall that you
know Trump you know at you know at one
point was separating families coming
across the border uh then he you know he
had the remain in Mexico policy for us
and people you know who are actually I
mean one thing that's interesting to
note or worth noting is that people at
the border are being processed they're
actually following the law and these
Venezuelans were processed they're in
the country legally and they're trying
to figure out where to go next while
they await their procedure you know
their court dates and stuff like that
but do we know what
um desantis's immigration uh policy is
or what's his attitude that's
immigration you know all the statements
I've heard from him is very very much
talking about securing the border so
it's in line with the kind of hard-line
GOP approach of we need to really
control there's too many people coming
in and uh we need to you know Pare that
down and you know in terms of the
dysfunction at the border like I think
everyone in every political Camp can
acknowledge that it is there
um and but it it's it's being
perpetuated by both sides you know you
mentioned the the remain in Mexico
program before that it was the Obama
Administration who was building the
detention camps on the border so there's
never seems to be you know a serious
proposal to
make either streamline immigration or if
you are on the Republican restrictionist
side figure out a way to like rationally
secure the Border without you know
building some useless wall that isn't
going to accomplish much
um you know uh we're trying to uh get
Carol back in on the conversation
hopefully she hasn't been picked up by
immigration maybe the uh yeah maybe the
papers weren't signed properly uh way
back when
um but um you know uh why don't we um up
I think uh we're here okay
all right hello Carol I got a note that
your audio is a little low Nick I don't
know if you're able to boost that on
your mic at all uh yeah I guess there
you go that's better
all right uh Carol thank you for nope
that's quite all right this does the
marvels of modern technology so um so I
just wanted to add just my final thought
on this is that um I don't love that
it's a pro
I don't know the sound just went out
again
she's yeah she's just Frozen okay
um well uh
let's uh
glitch
Central here
um
so
um yeah you know National conservatives
um are something worth talking about
especially from a liberal well you know
I guess from a Libertarian perspective
while we hopefully will get Carol to
come back in
yeah um it's
um
I'm going to uh
and um you know hopefully uh she will
come back
um but uh
from a Libertarian point of view what
what do you think is the default setting
on immigration policy you and I attended
the Reno reset of the libertarian party
which you know radically altered its
immigration policy from one that was
generally favorable towards more
immigration easier immigration to being
agnostic on the question so within the
libertarian movement things have been
shifting but what's your sense what what
should the libertarian position towards
uh immigration
yeah my my position is that it should be
as easy as possible for people who want
to come and live and work here to do so
as long as they're you know peaceful you
know not not obvious threats to anybody
um you know how that's done I think the
the Practical questions are there's
legitimate debate about how to achieve
that goal but that should be the end
goal like should it be you know work
permits like an expedited path to
citizenship
um you know uh you know visas that are
just kind of like rubber stamped every
few years
um you know those are all debatable
policy questions but I think um like
from a Libertarian perspective you know
as long as uh you know these are
peaceful people uh seeking work and and
a life here then I'm I'm all for it yeah
it's uh I mean I I agree with you
obviously in this I find worrying okay I
think we've got Carol back yeah I hope
so all right
now we're talking good to see you again
all right okay yeah
let's uh let's give it a shot okay you
were uh you were gonna say something
Carol that
um the Santas put this in the budget he
literally had it in the Florida budget
that he was going to ship migrants from
one place to another and the Democrats
in the state voted for it so when they
were outraged this in this last week or
so his spokespeople could say look you
voted for it you
um I I think it's a a real you know
genius move politically and uh I think
it was the right thing to do
um you know uh we were talking a little
bit about immigration more broadly and
Carol I know you have libertarian
leanings in your libertarian-ish on a
bunch of things but you don't identify
as a Libertarian and we're not asking
you to right but we're you know we're
staging this conversation because you
know we're Libertarians and so I believe
I love the Libertarians uh you know
we're the best I mean yeah uh but a good
time uh but
um you know what what do you think is uh
I mean do you consider yourself a
Republican or a conservative yeah I'd
say conservative
um I I don't know I think a lot of my
idea like a lot of my feelings and ideas
are libertarian
um but my work with libertarianism is
that I think especially during the
pandemic what I learned is that it's not
enough for like one person to be a
Libertarian it's gonna have to be
everybody in order for it to work like
so for example
um I my preference would be local school
districts making decisions it wouldn't
be the governor are making decisions but
what ended up happening during the
pandemic was the Democrats would push
for say DeSantis not to make decisions
for local school districts but Hogle or
Cuomo at the time could make decisions
for local school districts it was like
Tales you lose you know heads I win and
um stuff like that I mean Florida has
you know why why wouldn't you just let
school districts in Florida make
decisions because well in that case why
can't it be individual parents right
just take it right down to that to the
individual like why should just because
somebody happens to live in a democratic
businesses uh yeah I mean this is a
wonderful uh yeah I mean continue
so no I would say that the things that I
have disagreed with Governor desantisan
um well one of the things was the
business mandate especially for cruise
ships I thought like you know cruise
ships are a unique thing and uh they
should be allowed to kind of make the
decision about the vaccine mandate but I
don't know I now I kind of think I was
wrong on that because I think that the
businesses that had these mandates in
place didn't have a better result there
was nothing there was no business yeah
right it is it is their business and you
know in general I think I would support
businesses making their own decisions
but uh look what happened in New York
again the businesses couldn't make their
own decisions the private vaccine
mandate was only lifted today today
we're gonna we're gonna get to you know
how much better it is for each of you to
be in Florida than to be in New York or
California in a second but uh just to
close out kind of a conversation about
immigration and then after we talked
with them a little bit about the places
they fled folks uh watching on YouTube
uh we'll we'll get to some questions as
well
um but in terms of immigration do you
think I mean Florida is a state which is
gaining lots of people it's one of the
fastest growing states in the country
um to put that into context basically
since World War II Florida has been and
actually even before that it's been one
of the you know on annual or uh you know
Centennial uh uh censuses it is uh you
know it's been doing extremely well for
you know 100 years
um but it's got a lot of people moving
there
um should you know does it make sense
for descendants to be pro-immigration
because that's where that's how people
are showing up in Florida
and it's me or Zach me
um well I think that there
that the general is is finding it very
hard to be pro-immigration right now
because of what's happening at the
border when you're having 200 000 people
enter every month and it's not
controlled in any way I think it's gonna
be very hard to convince people that oh
we need more of this
um I think if there were more controls
in place I I don't see a Republican
party that used to be against
immigration I I don't think that they in
general would oppose immigrants um I
think what's happening at the border is
well I think they do now I I think
Donald Donald Trump was explicitly
against legal immigration as well as
illegal immigration Donald Trump is a is
a X Factor in a lot of ways
um in the Republican party and elsewhere
but yeah he sure he opposed maybe legal
immigration as well
um but I I again I think it's tied
directly to the influx at the border
even for him um he came in would build a
wall and that's you know it's very
specific it's not like stop the flights
and you know at the airports it's not
like you know check everybody's student
visa it's build the wall because that's
where the problem is
yeah I think that Floridian I mean
Florida Republicans should even just
from a purely self-interested point of
view they should want
Venezuelans for instance to be settling
in Florida I mean we saw that it was you
know the the hardcore like
anti-communists like Cubans down in
Miami uh really helped uh sway Florida
for Trump in a strong way
um this is like uh Venezuela anyone
who's escaping socialism like they're
they they've seen it firsthand they're
going to have those kind of values that
align with what Republicans say they
want so I agree yeah I think yeah so
that's um you know that's good generally
I think um immigrants add to
um the economy they add to our cultural
life um they they make places better
that was my experience in California
it's been my experience in Florida
um so I'm all for it and you know I I'm
not I don't object to the idea that uh
governor should could work with each
other and try to you know find places to
settle immigrants that you know might be
better if a town at the border feels
like their capacity is being strained
that that should be something that's
worked out it's it's the deception that
bothers me and also just you know going
out of state something has very little
to do with Florida
um and doing this and it's it's
been you know where have they been this
isn't
it's been going on
what did they think was happening
Texas towns and it's not like it's not
getting any coverage it is covered you
know actually the moving company that
moved me from New York to Florida does
like this yearly Cleanup in a different
city and last year they happened to do a
Border Town in Texas and they found like
I don't remember the story all those
immigrants under the Del Rio bridge that
was like my mover discovered them like
oh there's all these people under the
bridge
um Blue Line moving by the way really
good company and you know and and so
they did it again this year they saw
dead bodies they saw garbage Schroon
everywhere
um and it's it's it's a real real
problem that none of the people that
would support uh you know unchecked
immigration have ever had to live with
yeah I mean obviously if you're living
on the border
um you know where people come through
checkpoints you're going to have more
you know of that
um it's true that uh you know uh Trump
did not have a plan for border control
that was particularly effective uh or
Humane
um it's also it's been decades at this
point since we've had comprehensive
immigration reform this was something
that George W bush said when he got
reelected that that and so security
privatization were going to be the two
things he was spending his political
capital on that lasted about six weeks
um so immigration reform whether it's
comprehensive or piecemeal has been
elusive
um I think you know this is for me as a
Libertarian I have to say that the the
face at the Republican party and I think
this includes Ron DeSantis and the
national conservatives uh or so-called
National conservatives are very hostile
to legal and illegal immigration and
they'll they'll key on illegal but then
they'll be like well we have to have a
moratorium on legal immigration because
we don't have a comprehensive plan or we
are our Unity as a nation is our
identity is being challenged by too much
too soon uh that's a real problem for me
I think again if you fix if you fix this
the legal part I think you 'll see a
shift in a
paper yeah but there's no way to fix the
illegal part I mean the you know the the
the the big uh push the big increase in
uh illegal Crossings it's not because
people are suddenly feeling more illegal
it's because the American economy is
growing and there are a lot of jobs here
and if you're from Latin America and and
we should also point out by the way that
the you know the big sender countries
it's no longer simply Mexico it's also
India and China uh and a lot of those
people come in illegally although not
typically not at the southern border but
you know you cannot regulate flows by by
treating people like you know like their
drugs crossing the border you just
create black markets and intensify all
of the negative effects and and just
driving it further underground
um
yeah
Florida's net migration and immigration
if you combine those things you know
people moving within the United States
to Florida and from without the United
States to Florida that number combined
the summer between 2020 and 2021 or that
that year between those Summers that was
Florida was number one for net migration
and immigration gain and both of those
things I think have been very good for
the state like that is those are both
reasons why we've seen pretty uh
substantial economic growth uh here
um so I will tell you somebody you know
obviously I'm dialing in here from New
York City which has a lot of immigrants
although Eric Adams the kind of idiot
mayor the most recent idiot mayor of New
York has said you know we we can't deal
with any immigrants uh he's a peculiar
character on that wow but I've lived but
I've lived in parts of the country in
particular Southwestern Ohio that does
not have many immigrants and you know
immigrants go to where the jobs are and
like it's it's never good sign when you
if you're living in a part of the
country that doesn't have a lot of
immigration whether it's legal or
illegal you're basically living in a
part of the country that is kind of
dying economically and culturally et
cetera
um
but this also goes against the point
that these people are refugees and they
need refuge in the country economic
immigration is a completely different
ball game yeah I actually I disagree
with that I mean the Venezuelans are
specifically you know they are they're
booted because of political Civil War
and whatnot
um but um I think I mean my grandparents
were all economic refugees from Ireland
and Italy and they manage they managed
to squeeze in to you know the United
States before the the doors from Europe
shut and I shudder to think what would
have happened if they were even a few
years later they wouldn't have made it
in and I'd be in Argentina uh you know
panhandling or something to be quite
honest but
um okay so I just want to point out a
couple questions here zinc 17 before we
even got started wrote to write the
words the country's most controversial
Governor is a sign of reason being
possessed by the enemy's narrative okay
thank you that's great
um who would you pick uh Daniel Spencer
says who would you pick us more
controversial I guess talking back to
some of those people
um let's uh and zinc is just talking
about rejecting the enemy's framing of
controversy okay
um Josh Joshua Baratheon Baratheon says
as a Floridian I like the sentence I
don't always agree with him on some of
the smaller issues but overall he's a
great Governor
um let's talk a little bit about where
you guys came from uh and we'll start
with you Zach because you traveled
further you were you're you're a Florida
native right you grew up in what like
Central Florida the Orlando region in
Orlando
um you went to University of Florida yes
one of the most over rated football
teams really in history
national championships while I was there
thank you very much and a terrible color
scheme
um but uh but then you made your way to
California to the land of you know Lotus
Cedars and dreams
you ended up you ended up working at
reason uh you know and but then you left
a year ago
um why did you leave and why did you
pick Florida as you know as your
destination
yeah so I both traveled further and in a
sense not as far as Carol because it was
a homecoming of sorts uh but uh you know
it was
multifactorial you know it was about
family
um I have family here in Florida
um and
during covid as we all know everything
changed
um things were just getting the there's
just a more oppressive feeling
um creeping in in Californians
particularly La
um I took a summer vacation to Florida
during the summer of 2020 uh when they
were open and California was entirely
shut down
um and the difference was just so
startling and I think that was pretty
much the end for me like I was there in
Florida just hanging out uh by the beach
and being normal and I read on Twitter
that California just reimposed their
indoor mask mandate and I'm like I don't
want to go back there
um so that was that was the beginning
um and just like it just kept adding up
um you know things were deteriorating
the quality of life
um kind of the situation on on the
sidewalks and Public Safety
um and I think a lot of that will will
turn around but I have young kids and I
don't have a lot of time to wait around
I was disturbed by how the schooling
situation talk a little bit about that
because uh you know you were you were in
Los Angeles so this you know not San
Francisco but Los Angeles I spent uh the
last three months of uh 2020 in the
first five months of 2021 in Los Angeles
and it was it was disturbing
um you know I mean it was very pleasant
but there was a real sense that things
were kind of going down the drain um
there was a veneer of civilization that
seemed to be kind of blowing out to sea
on a regular basis um Talk a bit about
the schooling though because you know
part of it is you guys both have school
age kids and that's a time when a lot of
people leave cities or uh you know for
for a variety of reasons but what what
was scary about the school situation for
you in California
I mean first and foremost was just the
manner in which the teachers unions were
acting and the rhetoric they were
putting out and the ways that the
districts were caving to them I realized
just how much political power they had
in terms of delaying and delaying School
openings in terms of keeping masks on
very little children in contradiction of
evidence that this was not necessary
denying there could be any you know
harmful social effects whatsoever of
making like a four-year-old wear a mask
all day outside
um the you know there was
um rumors at the time I was about to
head out that they were going to impose
a vaccine mandate on every child and you
know I'm not against vaccines but just
the idea that the state is going to have
that much say in the raising of your
children and you know barring them from
end tree based on to you know businesses
or everyday life it it just started to
feel like a very um like
anti-parent anti-child situation
um and uh you know
how much cheaper is it for you like did
you own a house in L.A yes okay and so
like can you compare just kind of
roughly what your house was like there
versus the one in Florida cost I mean
yeah the costs are not even comparable
and I'm in La
um you know I got fortunate to get a
house during the slump but there's no
way I would have been able to to afford
a house like at the current prices
um and that's a huge reason why people
from LA and I think New York and New
Jersey are moving down to Florida is
there's just you can afford a little
more space to spread out and I think
after uh being cooped up in an apartment
A lot of people wanted that space and
you know people like me and Carol who
are in the much derided laptop class
suddenly have like the flexibility to
work anywhere
um and so lots of people uh this this
kind of already existing trend of people
moving to the cheaper Sunbelt areas just
I think accelerated rapidly because of
all those factors Carol what about you
what uh you were living in Park Slope
you had a kind of like a mansion right I
did rehabbed but yes yeah you know we um
we bought a house in 2019
um 2019 and we spent like
over a year plus renovating it um and
we're you know two immigrants from the
boroughs of New York Park Slope
townhouse is literally the dream like no
there is no other dream there's no Fifth
Avenue there's no Park Avenue it's a
Park Slope townhouse
um and we put everything into it and we
um definitely plan to raise our kids
there I know you you said uh that this
is the age that people usually leave the
cities I I fully agree I had so many
people you know over the time that we
lived in Brooklyn uh leave for the
suburbs but not us we were named we were
staying forever and in fact how crazy
things have gotten and how much things
have changed the only place that we had
ever considered living other than New
York City it was Los Angeles so
um the fact that we ended up in Florida
is bizarre but amazing uh we couldn't be
happier and it's it began in the summer
of 2020 uh the coveted restrictions were
definitely at the Forefront of it of
that
um the George Floyd riots were up there
for us as well
um but not it wasn't even that it wasn't
even these things it was not so much the
restrictions and it was not so much the
the violence or what was going on it was
the abject denial that anything was
happening from our neighbors
um just the Park Slope groups are so
like what crime what are you even
talking about like and defund police
signs in their four million dollar
Brownstones and it was really difficult
to watch and then when the schools
didn't open and all these rich people
got themselves you know tutors and pods
and they moved to their beach houses to
send the kids to public school there or
they sent the kids to private school and
they didn't say one word after spending
the whole summer Marching for Equity
about all the people who couldn't afford
to do this and it was just galling and
it started to hate everybody and I
needed to get out of there and Florida
became the Natural Choice and so can you
you know roughly uh you know like you so
uh have you bought a house in South
Florida okay and you know how's it how's
it stack up to the so I again I had a
good situation in Brooklyn which I don't
think a lot of people have
um and uh you know we had actually
gotten the house at you know a fairly
low New York price and because we
renovated it you know it increased in
value
um so we have a lot more space here but
I already had a good amount of space
there it wasn't like we were in a
one-bedroom apartment and now we get to
you know
um so it was it was just none of these
things that people normally talk about
with moving and it was our whole family
is still there
um it was extremely difficult decision
um and just the idea three of us leaving
New York my husband and I are just
hilarious it's like it was it seemed
impossible in March 2020 that we would
ever leave New York would you if you had
stayed in New York would your kids have
gone to public school because yeah like
three kids okay so and now they were
always in public
um I now have a daughter in private here
um she's like quirky and needs kind of
advancement in a way that my sons maybe
you know we're calling that
neurodivergent now okay no we call it a
genius in our house
but it is fun I mean and this is part of
why Florida and you know this this was
happening under Rick Scott as governor
was happening under Charlie Chris it was
happening under Jeb Bush Florida is so
significantly cheaper than a state like
New York or California
um Texas also is gaining people but
um you know how
um I guess I'll ask each of you you do
you you know do you miss anything from
the places you've left but then also
like is this is you know is Florida
running out of space is it running out
of housing because you hear so many
people because of the migrants right no
well yeah no I mean seriously but you're
you know I've I've been hearing more and
more Accounts at people or you know
trying to find houses for like 300 Grand
which is yeah a large chunk of change
but it's I think it's the average of of
housing prices around the U.S which have
been bit up uh during covet and whatnot
but that it's getting harder and harder
to find parts of Florida that are you
know move in ready
yeah I mean I uh yes I there are things
I miss about California I miss friends
that I had there uh I am you can always
replace friends
I'm sorry I yeah I I I I missed the uh
kind of no humidity like constant
temperate I miss like the mountains I
missed a lot of food um so there's a lot
of things I miss
um in terms of you know Florida and
housing the prices yeah they've been
going up
um uh uh housing prices been going up
rents have been going up especially in
you know the bigger cities
um and that is something that I hope
that Florida learns from California and
New York not to go down the super NIMBY
route um I think that they've avoided
that over the past decade
um but now there's going to be more of
that that pressure and those political
incentives to go that way and you
mentioned your intro you know our
colleague Christian uh wrote about a
case in Gainesville where the local
board one there wanted to change some of
the zoning to be able to build more
multi-family housing and so forth and
the state came in and you know is
fighting that and that's exactly the
kind of thing that happened in
California that is is bad news so uh we
need to be able to expand to meet the
need because there's there's plenty of
space in Florida it's not like you walk
around and you're you know bumping into
every people
um it's purely like will you allow that
demand to be met or not
yeah and that is a strange thing that
DeSantis you know in this Carol I guess
goes to some of the reservations that I
know uh libert some Libertarians feel he
was kind of jawboning and pushing
Gainesville not to change zoning uh
Gainesville wanted to change some zoning
laws that uh you know said that you had
to have only single-family dwellings in
particular parts of town they wanted to
open that up a bit and he was like no
don't do that keep it that way
um I guess two things one do you worry
that is Florida you know in New York
certainly had this California definitely
has this a kind of nimbyism that Creeps
in and it's like you know no everything
is perfect the way it is and we don't
want to change we don't want to expand
there's that but then there's also
within DeSantis there seems to be this
willingness to contravene conservative
Bible you know where you say like let
localities decide more things everything
is about pushing decision making down to
local levels except when you don't like
what they're what that decision is and
then you step in so I actually I don't
know this Bull story
um but you know Orlando for example
right now is considering rent uh control
something that we know is a failure has
is always a failure has never been
anything but a failure would I mind if
the governor said no you cannot I don't
know if you can I have no yeah again I
have no no idea if you can't actually
step into this kind of thing but that
and that would align with my values
right like I think rent control is
stupid and has never worked Florida by
the way did that I mean they got rid of
its crept back in in various ways but
about 25 years ago at the state level
the State Assembly band uh there was
rent control in about five cities and
they banned it at the state level right
so if it's possible I mean you know am I
supposed to oppose him doing that I well
I guess we're getting the question of
yeah I mean there's a question of like
if he does it by executive order and
whether or not that's technically legal
or is that bullying or is it the State
Assembly which is very Republican very
right you know can you uh Carol and you
know Zach I think I know your answer of
this but like can you comment on the
awfulness of the floor Florida
climate and kind of topography but I
mean that makes it all the more
impressive every time I go to Florida
and it's the same thing with Texas where
I lived in Texas for two years in a
horrible part of East Texas but like the
fact that people are moving there in
droves is a testament to how shitty
places like California and New York have
become because it's not like you're not
going to California you know or
Manhattan you're going to flatsville I
love humidity I love the heat I don't
know I thought like everybody kept
telling me just wait for the summer and
I thought the summer was amazing
um I and I went back and forth to New
York a lot this summer because we were
renovating here and
um every time I was in New York I was
like it is just as hot here but nobody
has a pool and it's like this is awful
you know it's not like whose pool would
you like to go to my I pull your pool
their pool you know like like it is in
Florida and New York seems to have the
almost the same heat
um I'm finding the rain a little bit
more challenging in the fall I feel like
everybody was like just wait till summer
nobody said to me just wait till fall
and it's not hurricanes or anything it's
just that everything keeps getting
rained out and I I I'm not used to that
I I
will say that someone who grew up in
Central Florida that is rough and it's
it's amazing to me that that is where a
lot of the growth is is in Orlando
Orange County
um because yeah there's not a lot of uh
kind of you know natural uh Beauty a lot
of it is like very uh you know paved
over and extremely flat there's lakes
and stuff like that I I live in North
Florida which I'm enjoying it's you know
there's some nice uh outdoor like uh
little streams and um it's a there's
even a little bit of elevation every
once in a while you'll be surprised to
hear but I I do feel like California
that's almost like a curse for
California is that they have this
embarrassment of like natural resources
that they've been able to free ride on
for so long that people will put up with
so much that uh the government in a lot
of ways just has not had to perform and
you know those natural resources
attracted so much industry the industry
created wealth the political class kind
of just uh rode that wealth for as long
as it could until it was no longer
sustainable and that's what we're seeing
happening right now is kind of as that
wealth evacuates what's going to happen
next what do you uh to bring it back to
DeSantis proper um you know what's your
sense of uh he ruffled a lot of feathers
uh when he went after the Walt Disney
corporation which at a certain point
um you know spoke out against the uh law
that was called the don't say gay uh
bill and we should talk about public
schools and and about the interest kind
of the interplay between the the
government and and the schools but when
he uh went after the Disney Corporation
um how does that do you think that's
good for business overall is it bad or
is it you know just kind of it doesn't
really matter Finance is actually the
largest business in Florida Agriculture
is Big Disney is obviously you know big
but it's not big in the way that those
things are but
um you know Zach what I mean do you feel
uh what you know what's your sense of
the business climate and how is DeSantis
making you know things better for
business worse for business or it's not
really a concern I so yeah I made a
short video for reason on the Disney
kerfuffle and uh I I think that
his his defense is that Disney had this
special government and he was just
taking that privilege away which it's
like okay fine fair enough but
um this has existed for you know decades
uh and it seems to have worked pretty
well yeah and you're just again kicking
the apple cart here because you are
trying to make a big uh symbolic
um gesture for the national stage I'm
taking on woke Disney
um there's the stop woke act which just
passed uh or that was signed into law
that is actually regulating what kind of
speech can be uh or you know what kind
of seminars can be run within private
corporations so certain types of like
diversity seminars are are banned and
you know however you feel about
diversity seminars
um it's clearly like he's taking this to
the next level in blurring the public
private distinction and he said that in
in Pub public comments he said that he
believes that these big corporations
aren't really exactly private they're
more like arms of the states do you want
to run that clip and then we'll come to
you Carol uh do you want to run that
clip if you can Zach this is from the
third annual National conservativism
Conference and the national
conservatives are a group that
oftentimes Define themselves as
post-liberal
so they want you know they want the
government to pick winners and losers
and they're saying you know like this
libertarian ideal this libertarian
Utopia that we've been living in my
entire life where you know the
government doesn't wet put its thumb on
the scale and it just lets markets you
know pick winners and losers that's
horse and buggy thinking and we've got
to Fight Fire with Fire okay uh run the
clip
uh the last few years have witnessed a
great American Exodus from States and
localities governed by leftist
politicians States and localities that
are failing on core sorry that was the
wrong one uh okay
we'll have Iris has inspected all
that all corporations are now exercising
quasi-public power we're not just going
to sit idly by if you're trying to
circumscribe people's freedoms and
that's true if it's government it's also
true of its big business but I think the
lesson for people on the right is I
think there was a generation of people
that kind of the muscle memory was just
if it's private just defer to it
okay then you know by the way that dig
muscle memory he's obviously attacking
Donald Trump
right uh Carol you are objectively pro
groomer so you must feel threatened by
people like Ron desensis but isn't I
mean by the way like isn't the and the
the groomer rhetoric that was coming out
of his press secretary's office is
insane right like this idea this idea
that the Walt Disney Corporation is like
this massive Q Anon Comet Pizza Resort
International you know like man boy love
Association that is batshit crazy right
I think you're looking at it the wrong
way and so it's it's not that they're
saying oh there's been Liberty this
libertarian Paradise the whole time and
now we're gonna put a stop to that
libertarian Paradise no what they're
saying is that the politicians have
directed what's going on in these
corporations the whole time it just
hasn't been us it's been the other side
right and so for them they're saying why
shouldn't it be our language they've
made corporations live under a number of
different liberal policies I mean I
think I'm thinking about Disney
corporation like there's no Walmart in
New York City because they just don't
like Walmart and they're just like no
we're not doing this we're not letting a
Walmart exist here this place at the
Chick-fil-A can't open I believe Boston
is one of them
um and yet Disney getting a little you
know wait so what I'm saying is
governments have always got gone after
corporations that they don't like what's
different here is that it's a republican
doing it and I don't know that I
necessarily have a problem with that I I
think the Disney waded into this
political controversy
um they had no business in it and yeah
they got punched in the nose I I don't
know I'm okay with it okay
if we were in that libertarian Paradise
I would I would fight to maintain that I
I think yeah I think it's a I think it's
a dividing line because yeah for me the
answer is like to the extent that the
government is forcing companies or
businesses to do things the answer is to
stop allowing them to do that rather how
has ratcheted up the next step I mean
the whole not letting them you know
you
know
in certain places like where that was
happening in you know Texas for instance
but now uh you know Greg Abbott who is
also kind of you know a shadow person I
don't I don't think he's gonna I don't
think he obviously doesn't have the
profile of uh of DeSantis but you know
there is a vying for what comes next in
the Republican party and Texas and
Florida are kind of you know they're
fascinating because within you know
they're massive States uh and they are
successful States and they are
conservative states that have a model of
governance where taxes are lower
spending is lower than in blue States
and uh you know people are moving there
on that so yeah I think the more the
more libertarian answer of how to fight
back against some of these trends that
we might not like uh is first of all to
start turning down Federal money for
things because that is how often the
federal government imposes its
preferences on stage and Texas has done
that sometimes there's been small towns
that have occasionally done things like
that there's you know the the entire uh
kind of uh decriminalization movement is
an example of just ignoring Federal
dictates you can you you can you know
sue the federal government uh or you
know helps help a private company sue
the federal government if you feel like
their rights are being infringed like
those are the kinds of things that I
would be more comfortable seeing
um rather than okay this has always been
a problem we have this marriage of
corporate and state and so we're just
going to embrace that and we're going to
make the corporations and the private
businesses do our bidding now
you must bake the cake like I just don't
think that these lawsuits are going to
mean anything
they won that case though well they won
the case and then now they're being sued
again and so like their whole life is
going to be expressing in the courtroom
it's like I how about we just to happen
direct uh people uh viewers listeners
Watchers participants to the aristaya
the uh the cycle of great tragic plays
where
um you you don't if you meet murder with
murder uh which is completely legitimate
and it's an eye for an eye you just keep
perpetuating a cycle you need to have
some kind of Justice you need a
different system and I that I worry
about this that you know if you have
right Wingers who are a senate and Trump
certainly signaled this uh you know like
we're gonna fight back twice as hard I
mean it's the Godfather and it just ends
with everybody kind of I Love The
Godfather yeah I know but you know what
you don't want to be living in The
Godfather you want to be the third or
fourth generation and in Judaism
in Judaism there's a big you know if
somebody comes to kill you kill them
first yeah well this is uh you know what
I I think Ron DeSantis is with me on
this this is a Christian country okay
it's not a Jewish country
no no that's a that's a creation of the
50s and 60s uh we believe in uh in faith
and salvation but uh let's talk about
schools a little bit because you know
this is also something and Carol I think
you would agree with me like if New York
City and this is also true of La you
know they're the two largest school
districts in the country if they could
have done something if they could have
done anything to make the schools
actually responsive to parents it would
be so much harder to leave these places
but they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
care
Florida and you know this is certainly
uh at least started under Jeb Bush if
not before was a a school that was a
state that was focused on giving parents
more choice in K-12 education and more
control
um Zach you mentioned you have you you
have two kids in charter schools
um that are like near where you live Etc
was anything like that possible in Los
Angeles well yeah Los Angeles actually
had pretty good school choice uh as well
thanks to uh mayor Antonio villarregosa
he was a big advocate of that the
problem is that the teachers union is
still quite strong there and very
adamantly anti-school choice and they
were leveraging this this emergency to
push to make it harder for charter
schools and they were not getting the
kind of support that I would have liked
to seeing to push back I mean they had
in their List of Demands were not no
more approvals on Charter Schools
um it felt like there was you know like
maybe the schools are being responsive
to a lot of the parents there and a lot
of the parents there are just not on the
same page as I I was regarding covet
policy so that was a big deal moving to
Florida is just a lot of more of the
parents uh it feels like kind of wanted
the same thing they wanted their kids in
school they didn't want them wearing
masks all day
um and the the momentum in terms of
school choice is still going in the
right direction whereas I'm not sure
where that is headed for La even though
they've got some decent school choice
now I'm worried about where it goes next
Carol uh we have you for about 10 more
minutes so uh let's let's uh ratat you
for a little bit and I want to point out
before I ask you about your kids
schooling experience
um uh Jim Epstein our executive producer
uh writes that I just ran a pull a poll
for viewers and it was asked was
DeSantis wrong to dissolve Disney
special taxing district 71 said no more
importantly uh another person writes
Nick and Zach are pretentious
intellectuals living in la la land Carol
is on point and real and you know what I
just want to just love you you
pretentious intellectuals
you know my house boy would you please
bring me another mimosa
um so Carol your uh talk about the
school experience uh you know where you
are in Florida versus uh New York so
it's funny because actually I loved my
kids schools in New York uh my daughter
went to a gifted and talented School in
New York City it's one of the first
standalones so she's gifted and talented
in Park Slope and she's kind of she went
to school in Manhattan
oh my God but she's autistic
okay she's actually uh very social
socially uh just doing real real great
um yeah you know if you just ever let
her see this okay
she's most likely to see this she's
actually a natural born libertarian
that's like another episode but ever
since the world will beat that out of
her yeah I know and maybe the employees
at Disney Corporation
um so she went to this great school it's
called Nest plus Sam in Manhattan uh
amazing mostly immigrants they didn't
allow any woke nonsense um anytime any
like wokeness tried to enter the school
like oh the climate March like my son's
Park Slope school they you know climate
large
um her school was like uh do it on your
own time we're not interrupting math
class for your planet March it was great
um but they closed the whole time for
covid the whole 2020 uh school year like
it wasn't even half days or part-time or
anything they were just closed um so she
didn't see her school until we returned
from our original Florida trip in May of
2020. but I I can remember us talking
about when you announced your move
earlier this year and whatnot I mean
that the the lack of
you know accountability and transparency
with the schools was a major factor yeah
schools in New York City and my sons
went to
a school in Park Slope but I which
actually wasn't very woke either
um and I think part of that is because
all the parents are so woke they just
everybody assumed they're getting it at
home
um and I you know I was an open
conservative in Park Slope and I felt
comfortable and happy and had the
pandemic not happen I think I'd be
living there today
um so I like their schools in New York
and then we moved here if a million
Americans have to die in order for you
to have an Awakening so be it that's
what you're saying
right listen
way fewer would have died if we had
followed my you know my current
protocols actually I haven't now and I
have not had covet yet and everybody got
covered at the reason holiday party
except me so I did not you know because
you didn't either wow
so just follow my lead
um and I I've really liked their schools
here uh so the three of them went to
public school we moved here in January
um my daughter's uh Public School kept
advancing her it was just she needed
some other things that we felt private
school could offer um it's our first
ever experience of private school like
we've never had kids in private school
before it's kind of weird and again the
private school there and I'm sure it's a
very good private school but it's what
about half the cost of half the cost of
a school in New York City um maybe less
that is I mean this is you know and I
say this to somebody who was born in
Brooklyn my family left Brooklyn in the
late 60s to move to New Jersey and all
of my cousins I hope we're not watching
this but who stayed in Brooklyn were
like how could you leave Brooklyn
everything is here right and then I
lived all over the country and like when
you get outside of the New York metro
area like holy [ __ ] I can get three
times as much space and opportunity blah
blah blah yeah or like a third of the
price what
you asked Zach what he misses about
California and for me I like things like
spicy Asian food it just I have not been
able to recreate that in Florida they
just it's not even close um I go back to
New York I go like straight to like the
noodle shop and but you can do that I
mean that's you know it's and the
distance and obviously like I ended up I
did a 30-year tour of you know the the
Hinterlands and ended up back in New
York for reasons I mean I like it here
and I like it here despite the costs you
know I'm willing to pay a premium
when you have kids it's different if you
know we're all in Upper income brackets
uh in a way that like uh one of my
cousins from Connecticut moved to
Florida this would have been in the 70s
and they she and her husband who did not
have college degrees were able to you
know have a true middle class ascendant
Mobile Life that would have been
impossible had they stayed in the
Northeast
that's right I'm uh I'm actually I'm
kind of optimistic about like the future
of restaurants and some aspects of
culture in Florida just because of this
this influx
um and even if you look over you know
the past 10 years in the big cities in
Florida it's been you know Florida's
always thought of as it's like you go
there when you retire uh but there's in
the in the cities especially there's
been growth in like the younger
demographics I've met lots of people who
left New York because or New Jersey or
whatever because their business was shut
down they have an opportunity to start a
restaurant here in Florida all that is
going to bear fruit if we're open and
welcoming to immigrants and continue to
be you know they'll bring that in so
yeah yeah
you've got a couple minutes so let's
let's just go to you and um
um you know like finish up
um what um you know
DeSantis you're a big fan is there
anything about him that gives you pause
or is there anything about the Florida
experiment that you think could really
kind of screw things up so I I guess I'm
a big fan but it's really like it's like
I've never liked my own politician
before like my my representative that's
crazy
about the last politician that might
have had any kind of like actual uh
change over my life
I was going to say her Gorbachev yeah
right
um but I was kind of a teenager so it
wasn't that dramatic but I think with
the stantis he literally made my
family's life better and it's it's a
wild thing to experience
um it gives me pause there were so many
moments I'm so used to careless
politicians who don't dot the eyes and
cross the t's that every time
um a story drops like with Disney and it
was like oh the taxes of the area around
Disney is gonna go up and then his
office was like no it's not and here's
why
um or with the migrants I was like oh
you stole these migrants in the middle
of I lied to them and then they have
these like signed papers showing that
they told them exactly where they were
going to go with like a map of Martha's
Vineyard and where it was and everything
um and so there's a lot of moments where
I'm just like you know used to
politicians who just do things and don't
really think it through he's extremely
smart I don't know how much people know
about him but he is like super brainy
and
um and and just all the all the like hit
pieces on him or like he takes
everything very seriously he is super
careful like it's like um you know his
college roommate says everybody wanted
to cheat on him and he wouldn't let them
like it's just it's stuff like that is
in the pieces so um I don't know I
appreciate that kind of leadership I I
like nothing in love with him
[Laughter]
um she yeah he also uh I believed his uh
Little League team won the Little League
World Series or at least Wednesday
right right enough already yeah it's too
much um do you think he's a phony though
because he's you know he plays a man of
the people but he has a ba from Yale and
a JD a law degree from Harvard and he
kind of seems to be talking
like a dummy
um see I don't I don't see that I see
him as being okay is he like a polished
politician no
um but I think that's really just who he
is you know his cowboy boots like none
of it's affected I I I don't think that
he is this again I don't know I don't
know another term for it except polish
politician he's not the guy who gives
these perfect speeches
um he's really just talking about what
he believes and what he stands for and I
think it comes across uh pretty in a
pretty powerful way
um I don't see him as talking down at
all I I think that he is using the
language that he would normally use
um so I had you know I've met him on a
number of occasions and he's very
personable but he doesn't have that
politician thing where you just feel
like they're driving you and like you
know at all uh so I don't know I I like
I don't know that you are qualified to
answer this question but what the hell
um if it comes down to you know Trump
versus to santis uh who do you think
wins in that Face-Off you know they're
both kind of hanging out in Florida now
and you know Trump the recent pass of
the Republican party and he changed the
Republican Party he changed the
direction he made it anti-immigrant he
made it anti-free trade you know he made
it a culture War
struggle in a way or intensified that
DeSantis seems to in many ways to be a
refinement of it he's obviously smarter
more talented I I want to say more
talented more detail-oriented and more
thoughtful as you were saying like he's
not he's not an idiot like he actually
does the work and and right he doesn't
work yeah so what do you what do you
think is uh do you think DeSantis is the
future of the Republican party or that's
yet to be it's it's really tough
um to enter like kind of just between
the two of them because Trump has this
thing that people are just obsessed with
you know for good and bad I think the
right that really loves him and the left
that really hates him he really makes
people feel stuff
um and I think that pointing to all this
is all the policy work I've done is is
hard to beat that again X Factor thing
that Trump has
um I definitely think DeSantis is the
future of the Republican party though I
think this is he's setting out a
Leadership Model and these other
Republican Governors are following it
and I I I absolutely see that being the
way that it goes I don't know what
happens between them just because Trump
is this complete you know just random
phenomenon
um so it's hard to say but the primaries
are a unique beast and I have seen the
the candidate who everybody thought was
going to win not win and some you know
Dark Horse come in and win the whole
thing or you know it happens it happens
quite often so I mean we'll see all
right we're gonna let you go uh I regret
to tell people that Zach and I will
continue talking for a while
Carol yeah uh we're in lala
Harold Carol Markowitz
follow her at Carol on Twitter
k-a-r-o-l thanks again thank you thank
you
um Zach what about you you know we
didn't really talk about DeSantis in
terms of uh things like gun rights which
is a big libertarian issue
um he seems to be yeah very hardcore he
wants to get rid of basically all
permitting of guns and things like that
um you know does that play well for you
or does it play well for Libertarians
a big short yeah I I think
constitutional carry is a great uh
policy to for Governors All Over America
to advance
um you know coming from California
the the law there for the longest time
was
um shall issue which basically meant the
discretion was left to the local sheriff
and if you're in a county like LA County
then you're not getting uh concealed
carry permit uh last year like personal
friends with the sheriff or something or
you're a celebrity whose bodyguard can
like you know you can pay it off for
your bodyguard to conceal carry or
something like that so uh that later you
know California had to give in on that
because of some some federal court
rulings
um but yeah I I think on that issue
certainly DeSantis is aligned with
Libertarians
how do you make sense of
uh
you know of like the overall package of
ideas and you know uh obviously we've
worked now together for I don't know is
it like 10 years or something like that
I forget yeah
um but I don't know that we've ever had
a conversation about kind of electoral
politics or partisan politics but when
you vote
um you know and you because you're in
Florida
um I don't know does the does the
libertarian party have a candidate for
governor they do yeah yeah I
unfortunately don't remember the name
right now but yes there is one and um
you know I know that you know Christ and
DeSantis you know they're the polls I've
seen are anywhere you know it it seems
like DeSantis is Comfortably ahead but I
think it's within four or five points so
you know a lot can happen between now
and election day but when you vote as a
Libertarian as somebody with libertarian
proclivities what do you um you know
like how do you how do you map out okay
well you know there's Chris whatever he
stands for then there's DeSantis and his
things there's a Libertarian Etc like
how how will you evaluate Iran DeSantis
because on some levels that know a lot
of the times that reason we we pick up
on the things like his you know that
don't say gay law
um yeah which was also practical rights
and education law yeah yeah and you had
an interesting you know video about that
because there are certain elements of it
that are I I find Despicable I do I
think the law is objectively kind of
homophobic and transphobic but it was
also like part of what it was responding
to was the idea that schools were not
transparent at all with uh with parents
about like what's going on with their
kids so I don't know like how how do you
how do you how will you make a decision
whether or not to vote for Ron DeSantis
yeah the the I mean the parental rights
in education law I you know that yes
there's some uh unfortunate aspects to
it I think it's it's a little vague in
you know what exactly a teacher is
allowed to say or not say in a classroom
the the thrust of the law was you know
ages K through three you're not supposed
to teach about uh gender identity or
sexuality in district schools and then
like you have to notify parents uh older
grades it has like could form with some
state level standards and then you have
to notify parents when things like you
know gender identity issues arise in
um school which I I think is completely
reasonable and generally like the idea
of the parental rights
um movement that the parents are the
primary caregivers and decision makers
for children that's good
um that's not something that I was
always getting from the state of
California or the city of Los Angeles or
LAUSD like I was not getting that
message loud and clear here in Florida I
do pretty much get that message and that
does you know put me more at ease even
if I might object to some of the
particulars
um and then you know that that's how I
try to evaluate DeSantis as a whole I I
agree with a lot of what Carol just said
like he's he's not Donald Trump even
though he's adopted some of his
mannerisms
um purposely uh he uh is more careful
and considered and um he does look at
data and understand it that was an
attraction to me when I was moving here
the way he handled kovid uh I I thought
it took a level of courage to be kind of
the first governor out there really
pushing back against it and say we're
gonna swerve and try something different
and it turned out a lot of those
policies
ended up looking a lot more rational
than a place like California so I give
him credit for all of that
um you know Charlie Crist
so far to me has been running a fairly
substance less campaign he's not a very
substantive person he kind of just jumps
from party to party like he's a pure
opportunist
um and kind of just defining himself as
like what is DeSantis I'm not that and
that's not a very compelling Vision so
as a Floridian you know uh I would not
be upset to continue living under a
DeSantis you know LED uh state house
um you know I I will continue to have
objections to
um kind of the excess that he's
demonstrated and uh this thing with the
Martha's Vineyard has really thrown his
judgment into question more so than
pretty much anything so far I'm I I
don't get it is it too much to ask a
republican a conservative and
particularly somebody in Florida you
know which has this you know this
particular history with Cuban refugees
and Cuban Exiles but I you know and and
I realize uh who who needs to hear this
but you know if he had said I'm taking
50 Venezuelans and I'm bringing them to
Florida to highlight the fact that we
need to be doing something different at
the border blah blah blah like he you
know would that I mean that would have
neutered the left and a critique of him
as much as whatever you know gassy
poured on the fire here I don't know you
know what yeah well like one thing he's
been pushing in education is to teach
about the horrors of Communism um like
he wants that to be part of the state
curriculum and I don't know I I I I hear
something from Venezuela right yeah yeah
I'm not in favor of government schools
uh but if they're going to exist then
teaching people about the horrors of
Communism seems like a good thing and uh
that could be something he could lean
into and say you know we are especially
welcoming to immigrants who are escaping
from communist regimes because we're
anti-communism and he could include you
know the state of California and New
York yeah you know so you can put them
up there with Venezuela and Cuba North
Korea so unlike Trump I think DeSantis
has some
um libertarian instincts like his whole
reaction to the pandemic was to say we
can't only defer to these Public Health
officials because they're only looking
at one narrow slice of the picture and
our job is to weigh different concerns
and kind of protect individual decision
making and individual freedom and rights
um and that was all very appealing
rhetoric uh and action to a Libertarian
um it seems like as that has receded so
has that attitude in those ethos and I
just hope that you know that that that
was that was legitimate and that was
real and that's part of who he is um as
as a leader so I think well this is
I'm sorry finish that thought yeah I was
saying he he so you know to the like
question of the this uh video here like
I think he could be a boon for Liberty
if those instincts
um Prevail but I think it's it's it's
uncertain whether they will because he
just gets so much attention by throwing
himself in to the kind of like
right-wing culture War like we're gonna
go against the world corporations one of
the uh problems too just I think as an
electoral strategy and this is something
that Donald Trump has shown Donald Trump
can't crack 47 of the vote of the
popular vote when he runs for president
and I don't think that National
conservatives and conservatives more
broadly understand that they are a
shrinking population in in most people
are not conservative in that way or
Progressive in the way the left thinks
so you can lean into those you know
those dumbbells you know those weights
at the end of the barbell
um but they're smaller they're further
and further apart from the center and
there's smaller and smaller and I wonder
if somebody like DeSantis now sensing
he's got you know he's got to win the
re-election as Governor but then he's
going immediately into mode to run for
president he's got to play to the base
um and that means you know sayonara at
least for a while to any kind of
libertarian sensibility because the new
Republican conservative is explicitly
anti-libertarian I mean and you can see
this in our comments here and this is at
reason TV which has been around since
2007. we have 800 000 subscribers and
our comment section is filled with
people who are calling Libertarians
pieces of [ __ ] you know right in our
feed and that's not indicative of our
audience but that's what conservatives
hear and that's what they see can we run
the other clip that you have from the
national conservative conference and
let's uh let's play that and then talk
about that and maybe have final thoughts
about uh Governor Ron DeSantis
matters of concern for
the last few years have witnessed a
great American Exodus from States and
localities governed by leftist
politicians States and localities that
are failing on core matters of concern
for for everyday Americans and they have
fled to States like Florida and we've
really served as the promised land for
record numbers of people over the last
many years the statistics are startling
since covid there's been more adjusted
gross income move into the State of
Florida than has ever moved into any one
state over a similar time period in
American history in fact if you look
over since covet the next closest state
to Florida in terms of receiving
adjusted gross income moving their state
as a state of Texas which is not too
shabby Florida has been almost four
times as much adjusted gross income move
into Florida has moved into Texas who
are the states that are hemorrhaging uh
wealth California Illinois New York New
Jersey you know you know the list
Florida's also led the nation in net in
migration since coven who has lost
people same cast of characters
California New York New Jersey Illinois
California had never lost people in the
history of its states and statehood up
until the last couple of years when
covid hit uh I had never seen a
experience a pandemic probably most
people here have never done that and so
I started to to look and research and
consume data because we were being told
what to do from you know the White House
task force or this health bureaucrat or
that but did any of that actually make
any sense and was any of that
justifiable and I look back at Dwight
Eisenhower's farewell address and most
people remember that for his warnings
about the dangers of the military
industrial complex and I think those
were a very smart observations but if
you read that inaugural address he
talked about this new phenomenon of the
Federal Government funding so much
scientific research and he says when
that's intermingled like that that
there's a danger that public policy
itself could be held captive by what he
called the scientific and technological
Elite and he rejected that as something
that was acceptable he said a
statesman's job is not to subcontract
out your leadership to a very
narrow-minded Elite the job of the
Statesman is to harmonize all the
different competing interests that are
in society weighing different values and
then coming up with the proper policy
and so my view was we had to choose
Freedom over faucism in the State of
Florida we had to make sure
foreign
excluding all these important values
okay yeah okay there's a lot to go over
there but and let's uh let's do a a kind
of quick March through it now one of the
things that's interesting you know he's
he's certainly right that states like
New York and California are you know are
losing population it's it's unclear
actually if California will continue to
lose in absolute numbers but relatively
speaking and it did in 2020 was the
first year that it you know in recorded
history they lost a congressional seat
yeah and and the uh and it also lost
people year over year which uh which is
pretty striking there are states like uh
Colorado uh which over the past Dozen
Years is also one of the fastest growing
States and is you know purple if not
bluish and it has a model of a governor
Jared Polis who I think in in many ways
has libertarian leanings and it might be
that if if DeSantis it's kind of a
right-wing libertarian conservative
polis might be a you know uh kind of
left-wing or a Centrist Democratic you
know libertarian uh and so it's not
fully clear that people are all you know
leaving that they're all going to the
same place and even States like Arizona
are becoming markedly purple after being
very very bright red for a long time so
uh which is another high growth State
um but do you what what do you take away
from his comments in that section that
you were talking about what what's most
important to you well uh first just to
address the migration to different
states which is absolutely true there's
something I do think there is something
a little different going on on in
Florida because it has been DeSantis has
made it this kind of for better and
worse like weird Beacon
um and you'll you've noticed in while
somewhere like Arizona has gotten more
purple Florida has gotten more red and I
would be shocked if Charlie Crist comes
anywhere close to DeSantis he has a huge
like boatload of money and
infrastructure here and has really like
kind of changed the the politics of
Florida and a lot of people came here
specifically to escape some of the stuff
that he was talking about and so the
people came here and it would be hard to
imagine them just abandoning those uh
values but
um what struck me about that speech you
know we played two separate sections of
the same speech that he gave at the
national conservatism conference and it
kind of exemplifies the mixed bag that I
see it's a Santa says because so much of
what he said there I resonate with that
like I agree that we have to balance all
these different concerns in a free and
open society that it can't all
um be you know know following you know
what is dictated from one guy at the top
of the federal government and at the
same time
um you know the second
three quarters of the speeches devoted
to this culture War stuff that says that
now conservatives need to uh you know
um make private corporations reflect
their values through the force of the
state and you know I think that if
DeSantis wants to ascend to the National
level the people at the national
conservative conference or the people in
the comments they can bash Libertarians
all they want but the reality is like
they need us to win they need us to be
part of that Coalition and uh if we join
the other Coalition then they're going
to lose and that the message that he
just gave there is what Drew people into
Florida and I think that it would be
smart if uh that was what was emphasized
and that was what um kind of was on the
front burner rather than this other
stuff
I guess that's not sexy though right to
say you know what we're basically going
to do we're going to have generally low
uh low regulation of business uh we're
going to keep taxes low we're going to
give people more Choice when it comes to
things like school
um that's not as sexy I mean I I am it
was sexy in the context of the pandemic
because it was like wow we're all
feeling this we're feeling this uh
entity breathing down our neck and he's
you know branding Florida as the free
state and that branding actually makes
some sense
um and so we are going to continue to
face
um authoritarian threats
um from at the federal level as well and
so there probably is a way to make it
sexy um and hopefully someone like
DeSantis can figure that out we don't
know yet uh what has like his views on
foreign policy really are
yeah I
yeah I I I'm not sure um you know he
referenced the military-industrial
complex there so um I don't know that's
a good sign yeah that's a good thing
like maybe he has some suspicions uh
having dealt with the kind of scientific
academic complex of like the way that
industry and um you know military can
work against the you know National
Defense true National Defense priorities
of America so that would be great if he
could kind of refine some of the better
Tendencies of the Trump foreign policy
like you know a skepticism towards just
jumping into every conflict if that
could be refined and improved that would
be great but I think so far you know as
uh someone who went from State Attorney
General to like I guess serving in
Congress to Governor hasn't had a lot of
foreign policy experience so he is a
vaccine yeah I mean he was like a lawyer
in the Navy uh yeah so that's going to
be all about who he surrounds himself
with uh so that's what that's what is
yet to be seen do you uh know offhand uh
what are his uh what what are his
positions on drug legalization
well so Florida has legalized has
legalized medical cannabis um and it's
been that way for a while before
DeSantis got into office he's been on
the record as saying he is against
recreational legalization and said he
doesn't like the smell of marijuana and
so he doesn't want that all over an odd
thing for a governor to be uh right uh
that like that's what's making him
decide not to do it but
um yeah so I don't think he's you know
libertarian on drug policy he seems to
kind of be you know I'm not going to
mess with the current medical regime but
he's not going to be the person pushing
things forward there and in terms of the
uh like abortion debate I know uh
Florida actually had a fairly permissive
law on the books uh which I think it was
even after the Dobbs decision was
something like 15 weeks up to 15 weeks
you could get abortion on demand but
then he was pushing very quickly to kind
of narrow that down I mean he is
definitely definitely a pro-life person
yeah he is pro-life but he wasn't like
these others I mean I guess this isn't
all doesn't all come down to DeSantis
because these other more socially
conservative States uh had trigger laws
that went into effect and just pushed it
almost all the way down to conception
Florida doesn't have that
um and I think that he he might talk
about it but he has not seemed to make
it a priority pushing the abortion laws
you know because I he is a Savvy
political operator and he knows that uh
the that
um that Floridians are not going to
necessarily react well to that you know
right before his election you know
pushing you know pushing some radical
abortion restrictions how do you and
again to bring it back to you know
DeSantis versus
his major party counterpart
let's say it's Joe Biden let's say it's
Hillary Clinton or something like that
how do you have a Newsome Gavin Newsom
yeah so you know and I mean in a way
I guess we can uh you know we can say
it'll be a clarifying moment if not for
the libertarian movement although I
think we can get there uh but for kind
of major Party politics if you have
Gavin Newsom versus Ron DeSantis you
have two relatively young relatively
accomplished Governors who have very
different conceptions not of the size
scope and spending of government perhaps
but of what what positions the state
should take on all of these issues but
is that even a tough choice for you you
would you would rather want to live in
Ron desantis's Florida than Gavin
newsom's California any day well yeah I
mean I think my decision speaks for
itself on that question if we're
nationalizing the California model
versus the Florida model which
increasingly looks like a possibility I
mean Gavin Newsom just said I think
yesterday or the day before that yeah
doesn't run I'm in
um and so we we might see that at
Showdown and that's that's like my life
playing out on the national stage here
the California versus Florida what about
it what about if it is uh you know uh
Ron DeSantis versus Jared Polis
yeah I have a pro-business pro-free
speech Pro social Pro alternative
lifestyle or I would say you know a
Libertarian lifestyle guy in somebody
like polis not perfect by any stretch
but I don't know you know like is is
that a is that a tougher choice for you
it is yeah
um it's a tougher choice I I will say
that the with the the with Newsome
there's no way I am ever voting for a
guy that I've been Newsome for anything
um Ron DeSantis at the national level
there's still a lot of open questions uh
about foreign policy and things like
this that's a really important issue for
me when I'm thinking about a president
uh but yeah a polis versus DeSantis that
uh we would I would consider us to be in
a fortunate position as a country if
that were The Showdown
and then finally you uh really
spearheaded our uh video coverage of the
libertarian party convention in Reno
earlier this year
I've worked along with you on that um
does somebody like Ron DeSantis present
an issue for the libertarian party and
it's kind of you know in its new skin
where it seems to be you know it's it's
more uh argumentative it's more culture
War oriented it is uh less
pro-immigration it is not it's agnostic
on abortion uh Etc does somebody like
Ron DeSantis pose a serious challenge to
the reason for the libertarian party
running a presidential candidate if if
he's the Republican candidate
um you know what you know what what
would a Libertarian voter be getting by
voting for whoever the libertarian Party
candidate might be whether it's Justin
Amash or Dave Smith or Spike Cohen or
Joe Jorgensen
well that's the that's the open question
because in the current mesos caucus
controlled iteration of the libertarian
party they could run Ron DeSantis as
their candidate if he would do it um
assuming that his foreign policy views
aren't entirely toxic I mean he aligns
with them on almost everything they're
all in on this idea that wokeness or
critical race theory is like a
neo-marxist plot to take down America
and therefore we need a Neo McCarthyism
to fight it back like McCarthyism was
actually good and we need that again to
go against this like subversive ideology
so they're like all in on that stuff
that I find Highly Questionable uh the
premises to say the least
um and uh the other stuff so I think it
would be tough for someone like a Dave
Smith to run against Ron DeSantis
um other than the war the potential War
issue for someone if it was Justin
amasha's libertarian party or he was the
nominee I think he would strike a more
uh visible contrast with DeSantis and it
wouldn't necessarily be that difficult
because he could offer the kind of
um you know decentralized uh
individualistic like uh and um
restrained government view that
um is a stark contrast with the kind of
national conservatism that the
Republican party is lurching towards
all right I think we're gonna leave it
there I just want to uh you know uh read
uh this is a new comment from Ryan s
saying if you're rich and entitled like
reason TV then sure fine California is
great for you but I do like how Nick
usually covers both sides honestly and
equally even though the left meets all
the targeting
um so
uh and then Alice Tusk says there was a
benefit for the migrant workers
to uh I'm sorry this uh yep she just
retracted her message
uh so forget that
and uh I guess we will uh we're gonna
leave it there I want to thank uh
everybody who was watching on YouTube in
real time particularly the people who uh
sent in poisonous comments that's always
uh you know that's what keeps us going
uh and Carol Markowitz has already left
us it was wonderful to hear from her and
her experiences of moving from the
People's Republic of New York to uh you
know South the South Korea of America uh
Florida and I especially want to thank
you Zach uh my reason TV senior producer
colleague who made the Long March from
California you had finally made it to
the West Coast the best coast you know
where the sun set and now you've come
back to the east coast so we're happy to
have you but thanks for uh sharing your
thought and your or insights into uh you
know a guy who is clearly going to be
one of the major players in American
politics and certainly Republican
politics for you know probably the rest
of our lives I think so thank you Nick I
appreciate it okay thank you and thanks
again to everybody uh we will see the
next time that we have a live stream on
YouTube thanks